well mr. Linton I see that you attended
the Royal Edinburgh College did yes
those halcyon days one of Edinburgh
finest schools oh yes indeed I look back
on my time there with great fondness and
affection the debating society the first
eleven the soft knock of willow and
leather I'm an all by myself oh really
and do you recall the school motto oh of
course
the motto the motto strike I've hope
believe and conquer conquer exactly
those very words have been my guiding
light through what is after all a dark
and often hostile world mr. Anton yes
you seem perfectly suited to this
position but to wonder if you could
explain the gaps in your employment
record oh yes I can yes the truth is
well the truth is I've had a
long-standing problem with heroin
addiction I've been known to smoke a
sniff a swallow a stick it out my arson
inject it into my veins trying to combat
this addiction but unless you count
Social Security scams and shoplifting I
haven't had a regular job in years